à mogadishu les médecins et infirmières
continue à travailler 24 heures sur 24
pour essayer de sauver des vies la
situation sanitaire du pays est critique
un adolescent vient de perdre sa mère
le corps d'un virus est arrivé dans la
ville nous avons besoin de quelqu'un
pour l'arrêter et nous donner des
médicaments qui nous permettrait de le
conjuré maintenant vous voyez que je
suis triste aujourd'hui car ma mère est
décédée
vous en verrez beaucoup d'autres dont
les parents mourant également le nombre
de cas en somalie est passé de 4800 à
plus de 6600 pour le seul mois de
février selon les données officielles
des données qui serait amplifié pour
étouffer les manifestations contre le
président au pouvoir le gouvernement a
interdit les rassemblements publics au
nom de l' pandémique pour le directeur
de l'hôpital martini il s'agit d'une
manoeuvre politique
il y à des rumeurs sur les réseaux
sociaux qui font état d'un nombre de
décès liés au virus beaucoup plus élevé
je pense qu'il s'agit des motivations
politiques
il est impossible que nous perdions deux
cents personnes en une nuit dans nos
hôpitaux comme c'est suggérer sur les
réseaux sociaux
la vérité est qu'au cours des trois
dernières semaines nous avons perdu
environ 50 personnes
la somalie comme de nombreux pays
d'afrique n'a pas de système officiel de
suivi des données sur la mortalité
ce manque de transparence fait augmenté
l'inquiétude des habitants
même le nombre de cimetières à mogadishu
et méconnue